yeah yes you sacrifice to Kelly and he
bring forth its opposite now it's I was
once I thought I thought I underst
I thought that I had come to understand
the idea of sacrifice I think I figured
this out about 15 years ago it just blew
me over when I figured it out because it
always been viewed either as a kind of
methods innominate or something that's
pathological but it's not it's the most
remarkable it's one of the most
remarkable conceptual discoveries that
the human race has ever made because
what it meant was we started to figure
out that if you gave something what it
wanted if you gave something something
of value then you could turn it into
something that might be beneficial to
you so it's though it's it's the
concomitant of delayed gratification
because delayed gratification is a
sacrifice so you know though the
marshmallow experiment right so you get
these little kids yeah I know you okay
so here's a bunch of them now if you
don't eat those marshmallows you get to
have more marshmallows and so then you
leave and some of the kids eat
marshmallows right and you got to admit
those kids there's something about them
the gift of damned marshmallows you know
and so if there was an earthquake right
then those kids would have won okay so
that's something to think about because
delaying gratification is not always the
right answer the environment has to be
stable enough so the the probability
that you will get what you've delayed
for is high and so if you're living in
sheer chaos you're a fool to delay
gratification it's like eat the damn
marshmallow now so so it's not about
delayed gratification is the solution
for everything it's not sometimes it's
the solution so what do you do you make
a sacrifice now and the idea is it will
pay off in the future so then you think
about that in archetypal forms it means
that you forego something of value now
it's a sacrifice you let go of it and
the deal is if you let go of it better
things will happen
you in the future and you know no other
animal has figured that out
well squirrels maybe you know because
they store nuts but I don't really
believe that they I think it's
fundamentally an instinct you know you
know what I mean I don't think they
generalized from that idea they do act
it out but I don't think they generalize
from it they haven't turned it into a
concept and so the concept here is the
world is constituted such that it has a
tremendously destructive element but if
you can barter with that properly then
you can flip it over and the part of it
that's positive will reveal itself it's
like that's bloody brilliant and there's
even another element to it because let's
say that all your all you've been given
from reality for a while is Kelly it's
all the spiders and snakes and fires and
skull you-know-whats and things that
want to eat you you might think and one
answer is well that's just what it's
like but then that's a problem because
that's not just what it's like you know
that the opposite is there and you might
say well where the hell is that like why
is it hiding its face for me and one
answer is eye reality is cannot be
contended ly that's one answer but
that's why you're depressed and hopeless
you're done here's another answer you
might be doing something wrong and then
you might think well what would it mean
to be doing something wrong and then we
might say maybe you're hanging on to
something you value a little too tightly
maybe one of your axiomatic
presuppositions like the thing that's at
the top of your dam value structure is
actually sufficiently outdated or
pathological such that if you hold on to
it all you're going to get is frowns and
misery so maybe you have to let it go
that's a sacrifice and so maybe that's
why the rule is when you're making
sacrifices to Kelly
don't sacrifice the low quality junk he
sacrificed the stuff that you're
attached to because if things aren't
going right it could be that it's
because you're attached to the wrong
things now that's interesting that's
starting to get very interesting because
that means that people are starting to
think maybe might have to have something
to do with this something I can change
maybe it's not just the factual nature
of the external world it's something I
could contend with and dance with and
maybe if I really MA
the probability is kind of low that
Kelley will be there all the time and
it'll be pretty high that her positive
counterpart shows up so then the
question might be how do we separate the
sacrifices that are necessary to
organize our schema of interpretation
and behavior such that when we
implemented in the world reality shines
its positive face on us and on its
negative things and like that's an
incredibly complicated cause right I
mean that aside that's wrong human
beings to be trying to figure out and
animals for that matter forever you know
was until there were human beings that
we started to get some conceptual
representation of it but then the other
thing too is you guys are all doing that
you have a big back going with nature
and the Vettius make some sacrifices
right now or maybe your parents are
making sacrifices on your behalf and
what's the bet - that is it'll be worth
it but what does that mean it means that
if you make the proper sacrifices you
discipline yourself you don't you're not
to dissolute with your resources you pay
attention and you wait your life will be
dead that's pretty cool
and if it's true then none of this is a
illusion or delusion it's just low
resolution first-pass representations
and that's smart and so we know from a
Piaget in perspective well what do you
do before you understand something yeah
act it out and so the people that were
making sacrifices they're acting out
this idea do they know the idea and what
you mean by no no they're acting it out
they're dramatically representing it is
that knowledge that's a form of
knowledge is it the kind of abstract
knowledge that we're talking about right
now no but it's the immediate precursor
to that you don't get from the
phenomenon to the articulation without
running it through some bodily
representations and some drama and this
is so damn complicated if you know you
probably couldn't get to it till you
have civilizations that were pretty damn
good and lots of people thinking about
this all the time you know and so the
person who came up with this they would
have experienced it as a religious
revelation it's like what's the nature
of reality poof you get this image notes
of this multi-armed goddess and it's in
flames and it's in a weapon it's like
terrifying you it's terrifying you
you're gripped by it and you make a
representation and part of the reason
you worship it is because the bloody
thing is got you in its grip and no
wonder because there's an idea behind
that it's so powerful that you should be
gripped by it
you should be unable to forget it
because it's a woman